this talk is going to
really focus on functional reactive
programming what that means
and to to really understand how
functional reactive programming
uh is helpful for gui's from games to
more traditional kinds of web apps and
so the real
key underlying question that that sort
of necessitates functional reactive
programming is
how do we do graphics in a purely
functional way so we know
the oo way of doing things where you go
and you have a thing and you modify it
but is there another way so that's
really how this got started so to
understand
uh functional reactive programming you
really need to take a step back
and and start with uh functional
graphics how do we
from building blocks get something
that's purely functional and composable
and has all these nice properties
uh that we're used to as functional
programmers or that or that we find
foreign and weird if we're if we're not
functional programmers
so the key goal here this is really how
elm got started
is i wanted to make graphics simple and
declarative i had been doing some work
with html and css
and i was a little frustrated
where things were a little weird and so
i started wondering how can this be done
in a nicer way
and for me functional graphics sort of
broke up into three
distinct parts there's text and links
this is what we're used to on the
internet
there's layout and there's also freeform
graphics
and so when you have something like test
text and links it's really about text
layout how do we put these words next to
each other how do we
make them flow in a container nicely but
when we start asking
layout questions in this same world we
start to get
weird questions so you say okay i want
to vertically center something here so i
have some text and now i want it right
in the middle of the page but
we're starting to stretch our
abstraction right when you use latex or
you microsoft word
there's a reason there's not a vertical
center option
because when you're working with text
it's really a weird
fit and so there's also this world of
layout where you want to stack things
and layer things and when you ask
how would i design something for layout
and how would i design something for
text
i would contend that you end up with
different abstractions
and finally there are freeform graphics
so these are crazy shapes that can go
all over the place getting scaled and
rotated
and again uh it's in a separate category
of layout so with layout you want to be
able to say i'd like to stack these on
top of each other please
um and then when you have a triangle in
a circle and you say that again you're
like well
what would that really mean and that's
an interesting question but it's not
necessarily one that's useful
in that if we try to combine all these
things we're going to get these weird
parts where the abstraction doesn't
really fit
any of the particulars that we want to
do so elm
introduces distinct abstractions for
each of these so it has text
elements and forms so when we
look at this in practice oops
all right how can people can people see
this all right should this be bigger
in the back it's all right okay so
uh we're gonna start with a really
simple one as text 42
and you can see we got a little number
42 so
if we wrote down the type of main we'd
say main is an element
and what this means is main is a
rectangle that you can
stack and lay out nicely and this little
aztecs function is taking basically
anything we care about or any sort of
value and
showing it on screen but there are lots
of other kinds of elements we can show
so say we want to do some basic we want
some words
uh
okay so we created this is called a
markdown block you can just put
arbitrary markdown in there with links
in
all the standard stuff and when we set
our main to words
this is what we see on screen and so
again this is another
element so when we add a type annotation
we can say element
and we're nice so we have a way to talk
about
text we have a way to
let's have an image so i want an image
that's 200 by 200
of yogi bear
and when i try to show this on screen
again it just shows up so we have these
basic building blocks of things that you
want to have in containers so sometimes
you want words in containers sometimes
you want
images sometimes you want video so on
and so forth
and so once we have these basic elements
we want to be able to start putting them
together
so elm introduces this flow function
so flow
types aren't showing up normally type
annotations show up here
so this flow function is going to take a
direction
and a list of elements so we can say
words
and then image and then i can see
these things stack up and so okay yeah
we know how to stack things
but if i say flow to the right
we have this as well yogi is chilling
over there
and we can flow inward outward
so and so forth so you get these ways of
combining
elements that's very natural and so you
can start to create much more
complicated layouts
in a very simple way you say okay i know
i want a row of these things and a
column of these things instead of trying
to
force that on something that is mainly
was designed
for text
okay so let's call this a stack of
things
so this is all well and good but
sometimes
rectangles don't cut it you need
something more fun you need
a pentagon you need a circle
so for this we have a special kind of
element
called a collage uh let's make this one
200 by 200
and in this case we're not taking more
elements we're taking
things called forms
so i can say filled blue and gone
with five sides and radius 50.
so the same kind of declarative style
that we used for
rectangles we can use for these free
form graphics
and so here we can have a whole list of
these things so
i can also say i don't just want to fill
blue
uh ngon i want to i outlined
solid red
square no we're done with squares we
want an
outlined uh circle
with radius 70.
okay and so already we have a fairly
complicated scene
and uh dotted
we can sort of mess with it as we please
dashed
um and the way we did it was this very
declarative interface
uh and so this is great for creating
sort of
very simply creating these complex
graphics
and one thing that's nice here is we can
actually start to transform these things
a bit
so we can say i don't just want a filled
blue and gone i want it to be
scaled scale by
two maybe that will be too big yes you
can just see the borders of it
um scale by 1.5 so when we're in this
freeform space
we can start to do sort of free form
transformations and what's really nice
here is that
we have this abstraction of elements
which are rectangles and rectangles are
a subset of freeform stuff so we can say
to
form so this is trans you can't see the
type
this is transforming let's take words
and it's a little big so let's scale
this one as well
0.5
and it needs to be at a rakish angle
so rotate by
30. okay so we went from
basic rectangles to this freeform place
where we can still
use all the uh same extractions from
before so if we don't want to just take
uh our words we want to take the stack
of things
again we can just drop this in place
so this is this is nice and declarative
and functional so what you can start to
do
is abstract out commonly repeated things
so you can have
a helper function that says okay i'm
going to make this red and i'm going to
make it dotted and maybe you use that a
bunch of times
so instead of having just a a
declarative language that has no
flexibility you have a way to say things
to clarity
and abstract out pieces so this is
really where elm got started
but it doesn't move right so we came
here for a functional reactive program
and so far we've seen functional
static programming to make
a proper gui you know they come to your
site and they're like oh this is really
pretty
and then nothing happens so i got to
this point in this project i was like
this is great okay
next and so one day i asked what if
values changed over time so we i didn't
want to do the immutable
things where you just go and change it
but what if those values actually were
changing
um this kind of blew my mind i was like
what if values changed over time and i
was like calling up my mom like oh my
gosh check this out this is going to be
amazing
and like the last time she programmed
was with like punch cards
and she was like i don't know it sounds
it sounds all right you should probably
see if there's any related work i was
like no
i know this is this is amazing um uh
and she was like yeah yeah it sounds
cool like i wonder if anyone else has
written about this
um so for a couple days i was like ah
and then and then i found out that in
1997
there's a really wonderful paper called
functional reactive animation
and this was really the first paper on
functional reactive programming so i was
late by like
you know 14 years but
it's still very exciting and so the
ideas laid out here
are actually very common in a lot of the
more imperative uh
iterations of function reactor program
that exist today
and so what elm did is since 1997
there's been a lot of research
uh continuing in this tradition of
function reactor program and solving a
lot of performance issues
a lot of abstraction issues how do we
make this really nice
and so elm is coming after 15 years more
of research and trying to get really
nice answers to how can we make this
efficient
how can we make it pleasant to use so
finally
that brings us to the beginning
functional reactive programming in
in l so what does this actually look
like and the key concept is called a
signal
and this is a value that changes over
time and various
different frameworks and projects we'll
call this a different thing
but you can think of a signal as a value
that's changing
and sort of it updates in discrete
increments so one example of this is
mouse stop position so this is a value
in elm
and its type is not a pair of integers
but a signal pair of integers which is
to say it's a pair of integers that's
going to change over time
to make that a bit more concrete we're
going to go back here
[Music]
shapes and
let's have a main equals as text
and before that gives me a
type uh an error
okay so the program we're looking at now
is
lift aztecs onto mouse position so we
remember aztecs from before
we just show values on screen but in
this case we're showing the mouse
position so as i move my mouse around
it updates automatically so you can
think of lift as saying take
some function and always apply it to
this
the current value of this signal so
this actually becomes quite flexible so
once we have this concept of a signal a
thing that changes over time
we need to be able to transform signals
so this is the lift function you saw so
we're taking
a function from a to b we're taking a
signal of a's
and we're getting out a signal of b so
we're doing a transformation on the
latest value
so the example we saw is you know
it's pretty straightforward but we can
do a bit something a bit more exciting
so
let's say we parameterize our collage
by x and y
and instead of scaling by 1.5 we scale
by
y over 100
cast properly this is why you have to
practice the live coding sections so you
don't get
type errors um and
let's rotate this guy by
degrees
and okay
and shapes
so quickly we'll go through uh i should
just demo this
so as i move across the screen we see
the pentagon rotate and as i move up and
down
we see the circle scales
and what's cool is this code essentially
didn't change we still have the same
declarative structure but we
parameterized by
x and y um and so when we say i want it
to be at degrees x well
whatever x is that's what we'll do
and so when we lift the mouse position
this pipes through
and so what's nice is as you add
interactivity
to your application you're not
fundamentally changing
how you wrote everything right you don't
have to write it the static way and then
rewrite it to be interactive or like
hook into it and do all sorts of crazy
manipulations
and so this becomes very flexible so we
can switch out mouse position with
well
with lots of other things that we'll see
in a moment um
so right now we're we have interactivity
but we have interactivity
right now right so again someone comes
to this
website and they're like oh sweet it's
moving all around and then
they're like how do i pay for this and
they start typing in
but it only remembers the current
keystroke
right so they say oh my name is and then
it disappears as it goes along so we're
only talking about the present
so to really make this robust we need to
be able to
ah we need to also be able i'm going to
come back to this
uh we need to be able to depend on the
past
and so the key function we use for this
is called
fold p and this should remind you a bit
of
fold l and fold r so or reduce depending
on what your background is
so you can think of fold l stands for
fold from the left
fold our fold from the right this stands
for fold from the past
so as updates come in on the signal
we're going to say okay i got this value
i have my current
value of this thing and i'm going to
give a new one out and that's what we
get as our signal of bs
so as new updates come in we can
remember what happened and and
make our application depend on that so
when we go back over here we can start
to write a little bit
of uh
past dependent code so let's say lift as
text
onto fold p of we'll write a function
here
okay let's first start with keyboard dot
arrows
so this is a built-in function
that
when i press up y is going to go up when
i press down
left right so we're representing
uh the state of the arrows at the
current moment
and this is using elm's record notation
so you can access with like dot x and
dot y to get into these things
um so this is all well and good but
let's say we want to actually when the
user presses up up up
up we want to keep track of how many
times they've pressed up
so we can use fold p we have a counter
that
starts at zero and then we need to say
oh the docs are working now um so this
is elm's version of lambda or anonymous
function
if you squint hard enough you can see
it looks like a lambda
um there there is unicorn support so if
you have a magical keyboard
you can use it and you also should tell
me because i want to use it
um so we take in this
this pair of x y and we take in our
counter
so we can say counter
plus x y dot y
and we're getting a little bit long here
okay so i just have a number now and
when i press up
it's going up okay this is proof of
actually pressing the button so up up up
up up down
so as events are coming in on
keyboard.arrows we're saying okay take
our counter and take the y
of that so when you're not doing
anything it's zero when it you
when you press up it's one and so we're
incrementing our counter
and we can be a little bit more fancy
about this so maybe we want to also keep
track of
x and y so we maybe start at 0 0
and instead of having a counter we have
a position
uh oh i'm getting lots of x's and y's so
i'm going to say
this is our direction from the keyboard
oh arrows
ah direction okay are we clear direction
i'm gonna call direction i'm committing
um and then we have a
uh x and y uh from what is our current
position
and so what we wanna say is i want the
current position x position plus
the x direction and we want the current
position y plus
the y direction and again
so as i press up up up up up down down
and down and down left
left left left forever
so and again this is starting to look a
bit like
our mouse position
we have a tuple of integers that changes
over time
so instead of saying as text here we can
say
shapes and
we probably should multiply things by
like a lot
okay let's not though and see
okay
it jumped because uh the size of the
canvas is a little big
okay so you have to press a lot of
things
and then i don't think this one will
even show up
oh there it is there it is okay
ah okay you can see it
okay and the real solution was just to
multiply by 10 so i could have done 10
times less work
okay now it's easy you know okay
so the same code we wrote before that
was for dealing with mouse stuff is now
working with keyboard stuff
and this this this wasn't the right
direction to go the really cool thing is
that now that we have
uh keyboard arrows um it's pretty simple
to start
making a shape that moves around so
it's going to be yogi it's got to be
yogi um
move to xy to form
yogi oh he's called image
no
oh okay yeah see you practice but you
know you can't you can't get it perfect
every time
to float okay so we have yogi bear
ah he's too big fortunately we can scale
him
okay we have tiny yogi oh crap
this is yeah bigger screens okay so when
i move him around
he's just moving around the world just
like hopping around and he can sort of
be like
um
so we haven't done a ton of work right
we sort of
messed with how we keep track of the the
what arrows have been pressed and we
said yogi is at
x and y position and we have the sort of
basics of
a little guy who can like move around
the world
which would be kind of crazy to do in
another setting
and so uh let's let's see how far we can
get with this oh my god how did
um
what is going on why it's got to be mono
space this is not
um okay give me a second
oh of course
uh so thank you um so
this is the beginnings of a little mario
program and i've filled in
some details uh so because we've kind of
covered them already
um so it breaks up into three
distinct parts we have a model of what
is it that we're trying to represent
we have a way to update that model and
we have a way to display it
so if we look at the display i'm going
to
get you guys to focus on this section so
it's a collage that we've seen before
and we want a rectangle so
this notation i might use this a bit
it's
it's application if you know
uh so saying um f of x is the same
as saying x is given to f
um so it's a way to save parentheses and
i know that's a controversial topic here
um but it's possible i'm not saying it's
right or wrong
um so we draw the
sky we draw
the grass and we draw mario
and we won't have to change this
throughout all of the updates that we do
um and one fun thing is uh okay we'll
get to that later
okay so our model is basically saying
what it means to be mario what is mario
at his core
in his soul he's x and y position
and an x and y velocity this is really
what we need this is what it means to be
mario
um and then we have a way to update
mario so we're going to take
some inputs from the world maybe that's
keyboard maybe that's time
in fact it's actually both of those
things um and we're going to update
mario somehow
and so this all gets put together in a
section that i've labeled
mario i don't know exactly i haven't
gotten the right name for this section
um but elm code's always going to break
up into these kind of these three key
parts and then another part to like put
things together
and you shouldn't always call it mario
so let's at the moment look at what
input means okay so right now input is
set to
fps 25. um so this is a built-in thing
that's going to give you a steady frame
rate of 25 frames per second
and it's a signal right yeah it's a
signal so this is changing over time and
what we're seeing here is a time delta
that's spit out at as close as it can
get to 25 frames per second and it's
hovering around 40 milliseconds
and if you do the math that's that's
right
right so we're getting these frames
time deltas and so when we look at
how we're putting everything together
here
we're saying fold p fold from the past
we're taking our input so this is a time
delta
and we're stepping mario forward by
these time deltas when we look at the
step function which is too far away
it is taking these time deltas
or in mathy words delta time
we can start to mess around with mario
and right now we're in that same place
we were before where
we have a mario game and it looks really
promising like oh how do we get started
and it
doesn't do anything so
the first thing we want to add is
probably gravity so we're gonna take
oh no no we don't want gravity before we
have gravity we need physics
what was i thinking um
[Music]
okay so we take dt and mario
and we can just say all right i want
mario where so this is
elm's record update syntax so records
are kind of like objects but kind of not
um and so what we're going to be saying
here is take
mario and update these particular fields
so you want to change
mario's x to be mario.x plus
mario.mario.vxv
oh my god dt okay so
we're taking his current position and
updating it by the velocity and the time
that has passed
and to be a little more consistent we
should do that with
his y as well
mario dot v y times dt okay so we have
physics now
but despite that mario is just sitting
around
so something has gone wrong so if we
look at our model
we gave very boring starting things for
his velocity
so if we switch this around
we see that physics physics is working
so this game is i don't know this is one
of my favorite iterations of the game
like i kind of am always sad to change
it from this
um and there's a kind of like sadness
when he goes away you're like oh
did i win no
okay so let's have him stand still and
now that we have physics we can actually
start to mess around
with changing the velocity ourselves
so let's say we have ah this was the
function i said we're going to come back
to
okay we came back to it perfect yes so
we have this function called lift
two um it's a way of combining two
signals
ah okay
keyboard dot arrows so keyboard.arrows
we saw from before
and then i did a bunch of stuff that's
not that i didn't explain well enough
yet
um okay so we're looking at our input
and we added a bit to it so this
operator here
is saying take two things and put them
together in a pair
and we have the same fps and now we have
keyboard.arrows so when i move
around we see those things move around
so our new input isn't just dt it's
actually
a time delta and
a direction okay
so oh i didn't actually do it yet
um so let's make mario walk
and we're gonna give him an x which way
he's walking
and so we can say mario equals
mario where his vx gets set to
hex
no oh man this is always the hard part
actually applying the functions that
you've written
okay so
mario zooms around like a maniac i'm
impressed that he got back to the same
spot
uh so let's divide this by like a lot
okay okay so this is more reasonable we
have mario and he can walk around
and this is good but he can't jump i'm
trying to jump he's trying to jump he
really wants to jump he knows that he
needs to it
his life depends on it um because when
the goomba comes
okay so let's have a way to jump as well
mario where mario so in this case
we want to probably mess with the y
velocity and
to float no that's crazy
um there are specific cases where we
want to be able to jump right so if
someone presses
down you don't we don't really want to
jump then
like what does that mean like i don't
know
so we want a specific case if
y is greater than zero okay if someone
pressed up
then we want mario's velocity to change
to
let's make it 0.5 otherwise
we want mario we just we don't want to
change anything about
so we can say jump dir
dot y do all those other things
so we have our same old mario he can
walk around
and then when we jump
he flies away
so again this is pretty great i like
this a lot
but it's not very practical i guess it
lets you win
because you can just jump and then just
like fly across the whole world and
finish it like
way up in the sky um but this is not
ideal so now we actually do need gravity
see gravity it comes later um
i found it surprising also that like
part of mario is like you need to write
gravity i don't know it seems
okay anyway let's do it um
so we want mario where so gravity's
going to act on
the velocity um so we have his
mario where his y velocity gets updated
to be
his current velocity plus no
minus that'd be some freaky gravity
minus
dt over a lot
no that's too much no
okay and of course we have to apply the
function
all right this is going to be great does
anyone see what's going to happen
okay
so we're doing pretty well um we have
gravity
and it's cool because it feels like he's
falling to the center of the earth but
if you think about it
his earth really is flat and he's just
falling
there is this i don't know um
okay so uh i think that means our
physics is wrong
right so like we can't just have him go
down we need to have him stop at some
point
um and so we can do a little trick here
so we can say his new
x is going to be the maximum of zero or
whatever physics determines it should be
right so in the case of he goes negative
we say no no no we
actually want him to stop at the earth
well the
infinite plane that he lives on um
okay so we try this again and we have
mario walking around
we have him jump and it's
it's nice but it's like it's not it's
not perfect because like when
we can actually jump at any moment
so this is like the ultimate hack this
is like elm or
mario no clip so we can just like go
across the world
and the goombas are just like i'll get
you um
so we need we need to do better
so our jump function just says is the
person pressing up
well yeah but we need other constraints
mario can only jump when he's on the
ground so
and mario dot
y equals zero
so now his world is getting smaller and
smaller
so now when i try to jump as high as i
want
i can't do it i'm just holding down
right or holding up now
so he's like ah he remembers times when
he could fly
um okay so we have a lot of stuff going
on here and
the code we wrote was i mean
this is our update section right so we
wrote
these nice little functions that we can
test independently
how does this uh how does gravity work
okay gravity is fine we need to mess
with another
part of the world so we saw gravity was
always working but physics
wasn't stopping the ground and so you
can think of these very independently
and then just compose them together
we put together our two inputs and one
last thing that we might want to do is
we have this render function so like
right now mario
like exists just like frozen he's like
but we can do better than this and
what's cool is we don't have to mess
with any other part of the program
except display
so mario is an argument to our render
function
and instead of just we have some source
images here
instead of just saying okay mario is
going to stand to the right we can
give mario a verb so if
so this is going to be using elm's
multi-way if so you can have a bunch of
branches
so if mario dot
y is greater than zero
he's jumping
and if mario dot
v x is
sorry not equal to zero then he's
walking
otherwise and so otherwise this is just
an alias for true
uh so it's like okay we'll do this um
and so
it'll once we get to a true thing we're
going to hop to that
bridge so otherwise
mario is standing
and due to
careful gift construction
we can just add this in and
okay so when we jump he's actually you
know
um and when we walk you can see him very
brisk pace when he walks backwards
moonwalk okay
i i wish i had the music for that right
just like
michael jackson okay um so we also have
this information that we actually know
which way he's facing
so we can say direction equals
if mario dot v x
is less than zero then
left sorry else right
okay and so we can add this in again and
again
carefully constructed gifts
so now he walks this way and when he
walks the direction he actually is
facing the right direction
now there's one problem left in this
okay so he jumps it looks fine he walks
over here now when he walks to the left
he flips around because we say well
if it's less than zero then left but we
actually mean
if he was walking left then we want to
keep him facing that direction
and what's interesting is when we look
at our model
we actually don't have that information
there's no way to know where he was
facing last um and so that means when we
want to add something like this in it's
very clear we need to go to our model we
need to
actually put this into our like
well-defined
system of what it means to be mario it
turns out i was being overly simplistic
he also has a what direction was he
going um
and that updates that means we have to
change our update a little bit
and that means we have to change our
display a little bit but each of them is
an independent
piece and when you need to modify
something it always points back to
is your model correct do you have the
right way of thinking about this and so
i am not going to go through what it
means to mess with mario in this way
perhaps this is an exercise
but that's a fun one so
i almost fit it all on one screen so
this is the whole program
and we can look at line numbers
so we have 40 42 lines okay we have like
that doesn't count
we have so let's call it 40. it's called
40.
um we have 40 lines to make
certain mario walk around and sort of do
all these things and
each step was fairly straightforward and
so i think
this is this kind of approach uh scales
well to
general gui problems so this is very
specific to like how mario works but the
scope of problems that exist for gooeys
is much larger
so we've asked like what what if values
changed over time we've sort of gotten a
taste of that
and i sort of wanted to take an
opportunity to say how has elm changed
over time and where is i'm going
so i spoke at emerging languages
conference last year
i thought this would be a good time to
like reflect on what have i been doing
with my life
since then and sort of what's happened
to l
um so there is this there is a timeline
of what we've seen today so the sort of
key
things that have been going on have been
it started with concurrent frp so this
is sort of the theoretical
foundation of how elm works
ideally we can get concurrency working
but with javascript it's a bit harder
than it would be on other platforms
you have these trade-offs there's also
markdown support and extensible records
this is something that i'm
i'm really excited about but i don't get
to talk about a lot but it's a very
flexible way
to have uh records in a
statically typed way so we saw we can
update things but in fact you can extend
things and delete things from them and
put them together
in a way that is very uncommon in
statically typed language so you get a
lot of the flexibility of something like
javascript
but in a way where your compiler can say
hey you're using x but there is no x
there's no more like accessing dot x of
undefined
and this all led to a pldi publication
so this is a programming language
conference and sort of this was all
about how does concurrent frp work and
how does this fit into the
research that's happened since
functional reactive animation in 1997
and so after sort of this time period i
joined prezi so i'm now working full
time at present this
although this is a prezi i'm working
normally i write it in elm but
this time it's a prezi um i started
working at prezi full-time on elm so
uh sort of focusing on what happens next
with elm
um and so that has meant the scope of
the project has been able to get a lot
bigger so
i'm thinking about like what's the path
to practical frp
how can we use this in industry what
problems are really good fit for this
kind of thing
and so you can think of what i've been
working on before it's kind of the
theory side of things what are the
underpinnings of this how do we get them
efficient
and now i'm moving more towards practice
like how do we
make this accessible approachable and
useful in a in a production environment
where there's other code living
so the key things that i've been
focusing on since then is how
to integrate with html and javascript um
how to debug this is a common question
that people ask and so
uh and also how does frp look for
traditional gui so you have your uh
text boxes and buttons all interacting
and form validation and so on and so
forth
and so the key features that have been
happening since then are
actually doing html embedding how do i
put an elm program into a tiny box on
screen
so when you pitch to your boss you say
okay i just need these
this hundred by hundred square like i
don't need the whole page
um uh fixing up the type checker so it
turns out type checkers are hard
i don't know if any of you guys knew
that it's it's like a little tricky
um so one of the big projects that
happens inside joined prezi was actually
getting a really solid
efficient type checker um and so when
you see when you mess up
i'm gonna say hey like i see what you
did there
here's here's what's going on um another
one is hot tommy i forgot to show hot
swapping hot swapping
okay there's time for this um
so we have our mario program right and
we have this hot swap button which i
like mysteriously never pressed
um and so let's look at we have gravity
and right now it's at 400 let's make it
like
let's make it 100. now keep in mind that
the state of mario
is based on what we've done throughout
the program
and so we changed this gravity function
and when we press hot swap
the state is maintained but now when we
jump
oh did i i moved in the wrong direction
didn't i
yeah i want weaker gravity that's no fun
okay yeah hot swap okay
wow okay and so what's nice is
uh you can go arbitrarily deep into your
application so maybe you have a bug that
only happens 10 minutes in
you can go to that particular place
tweak your code a little bit
hot swap in and see if that fixes it and
you're like no no okay
and so there's a guy working on a
debugger that will let you rewind
so that you can actually retry these
things again and again
oh okay and so that's hot swapping and
this is
in a lot of ways thank you this is a
like a debugging tool but also like how
can we
program in a more expressive way um and
finally doing some industry talk sort of
saying this is what frp is about how
does this fit in with
what you guys are focusing on how can
this fit into like how can we do a
widget in twitter that does this or or
something like that
um and so uh what's next is um there are
two projects on the way these are some
of the short-term ones
ones to do frp the idea was that to do
mvc was kind of like the basic
proof of concept of any mvc library
and so the goal is to do a basic one of
these in elm
so it's a little rough graphically this
is in the work still
but we can say okay go to the store this
is a very basic to-do list like
we need every step of the way get milk
drink milk pay for a milk
um and we can just get rid of these
things as we please
um and so again this is a little demo
elm
program and the internet's not working
and i
don't imagine that this is incredibly
readable but the point i wanted to make
here is that it breaks up into these
same parts again we have a model we have
a way to update it and there's a way to
display it
and so when we look at our display oh my
god this isn't okay
five minutes oh it's passed
[Music]
um okay so that's a practice path
uh that's functional reactive
programming in elm thank you very much